bonjour vous souvenez de moi je
m'appelle élite gimenez j'ai 21 ans je
vis dans l'oise et j'ai participé à la
conférence sur l'avenir de l'europe
c'est marrant on en a pas beaucoup
entendu parler de cette conférence et
pourtant c'est notre avenir qui se joue
tout a commencé par un coup de téléphone
on nous a proposé à moi et 800 autres
rentrées tirées au sort de nous inscrire
pour dire quelle europe on veut pour
2035 bah c'est une chance à saisir en
honnêtement quand il a lancé cette
consultation depuis le parlement
européen le président a promis de tenir
compte de notre avis pour changer
l'europe qu'est l'europe voulons nous
dans dix ans dans 15 ans je sais que la
convention climat a déçu beaucoup de
monde mais bon j'ai quand même envie d'y
croire ça doit être mon petit côté
toujours optimiste la première étape de
la conférence s'est déroulée dans les
régions moi j'étais à lille mais il ya
eu aussi des débats tout un week-end à
toulon toulouse rennes aubervilliers
strasbourg et même à la réunion
on a vraiment pris l'avenir de l'europe
entre les mains on est un peu devenu des
eurocrates
place maintenant à l'étape nationale
l'idée c'est de rassembler toutes les
propositions faites dans les régions et
de fixer dix priorités pour changer
l'europe dans chaque ville des citoyens
ont été tirés au sort pour aller à paris
certains d'entre nous n'ont encore
jamais vu la tour eiffel c'est le cas
d'alan qui vit à marseille volley
pour subtiliser de marseille par la mer
il a été tiré au sort avec chahrazed je
pars ce week-end tu vas à la conférence
violent pour prouver c'est ça ces deux
marseillais qui ne se connaissaient pas
avant la conférence se sont vraiment
pris au gel des salaires minimums la
même porter pays d'europe métier le mec
qui est le même ils se sont rendu compte
qu'il n'y connaissais pas grand-chose à
l'europe
la preuve c'est la page la commission
européenne ou
du cou avant d'aller à paris ils ont
fait un crochet par bruxelles pour aller
visiter les institutions européennes
voit l'arrivée
commission sur bmo européenne olympiques
comme ici chaque tuerie lna stella c'est
vraiment tourner notre première chose
que je fais je comptais femme parce
qu'aujourd'hui en fait je me dis dans
les femmes escaut sont bien représentés
hélas
2014 chez moi c'est beau enfin
une fois un bel endroit pour montrer que
la femme elle a sa place
ça y est
cinéma
ya quoi comme film
on est rentrés nos yeux salle où il y
avait les journalistes tous les midis je
crois qu'ils ont un programme oui des
batman demi-heure bien bonjour et
bienvenue à notre réunion de midi
j'appelle sonia à me joindre sur le
podium pour une annonce sur l'année
européenne de la jeunesse et des porte
parole par domaine les points de vue des
jeunes d'âgés lors de la conférence sur
l'avenir de l'europe façonneront
également les actions et les événements
organisés au cours de l'année très peu
de temps il parle de beaucoup de choses
il faut il ya beaucoup de tels
articles images quelques petites
précisions à propos de la conférence
climat glasgow kosovo votre réponse une
autre kosovo la justice polonaise est ce
que les autorités polonaises ont déjà
accepté la présence de la délégation des
vaccins est ce que la commission pour
évaluer de signer un contrat clorox la
fiscalité
des entreprises
non mais ça passer du coq à l'âne j'ai
pas réussi assure
en plus il ya tous les accents donc je
parle quand même un peu anglais en ait
ok mais le truc c'est qu'il ya des
accents on se dit mais qu'est ce qui
vous
a tant pis
faut de quoi choquer obtenu une 5e very
much ainsi eu tout bon j'espère que vous
avez trouvé ça intéressant on perd
intéressant très technique
mais c'est énorme la quantité
d'informations vous avez on est l'unique
institution au monde avec la maison
blanche tous les jours à répondre aux
questions des journalistes l'effort de
transparence en tout cas ravi de vous
rencontrer
de rien et on est toujours aux
dispositions si vous avez des questions
merci merci beaucoup aux
prochaines étapes c'est le parlement et
je me rends compte que je n'ai pas voté
bonjour bonjour bonjour denis brassard
à z bien daily motion au parlement
européen c'est la maison des citoyens
européens we do marseille j'étais ce
week end cbg d'or qu'est-ce que j'ai
bien mangé et surtout je vous emmène
voir quelque chose entrée au sein du
parlement européen comme vous pouvez
découvrir chaque parlementaire donc
chaque député est rangé selon son pays
et nous avons dans cet étage un casier
c'est à dire une petite entrée où on va
récupérer justement des documents qui
viennent eux pas forcément des citoyens
européens mais de l'ensemble des ces
fameux lobby les lobbys c'est quoi c'est
à dire parfois ces groupes de pression
qui essaie justement d'influencer la loi
et donc ils ont droit au sein du
parlement européen de déposer selon
leurs députés moi c'est là et va leur
petit courrier leur petit document pour
nous informer de leur position sur tel
était le projet et ses lobbys viennent
comme ça alors c'est pas non plus un
moulin à vent lors on peut rentrer au
parlement si on est à créditer est ce
que c'est vraiment une puissance eux qui
prennent toutes les décisions ou pas un
bail faut justement avoir des députés
qui résistent parce que nous notre rôle
de député européen s'est pas de défendre
les intérêts privés des uns et des
autres c'est de faire la loi pour
l'intérêt général notamment les citoyens
européens alors il est vrai que
bruxelles est réputée comme étant une
capitale des gaules lobbyistes et soins
il ya des accords entre
lobby et certains parlementaires ici
alors il faut savoir qu est ce qu on
appelle lobby on peut avoir des méthodes
de lobbies venant d'auch ong les ong
environnementales met la pression par
exemple pour avoir une ambition
climatique sur tel et tel projet de loi
qui va être impressionnante là ce sont
des ong tandis qu'ana d'autres par
exemple on peut avoir des lobbyistes de
l'industrie automobile qui avons essayé
de pousser notamment pour les normes
soient moins contraignant
bonjour bonjour thierry mariani sarr est
celle d'il ya un chantier merci parce
qu'il fait beau à bruxelles donc je
pense que vous nous avez apporté le
soleil de notre région exactement le but
écoutez on va aller dans l'hémicycle ah
ouais d'accord ok c'est vraiment comme à
la télé quoi et ça fait du monde voilà
vous avez les groupes qui sont répartis
donc ça va de l'extrême gauche à
l'extrême droite mais du coup vous à
troll c'est quoi en fait en commun
commissaires parce que si vous
franchement tu sers moi je suis à la
commission des affaires internationales
donc moi je lui dit vous êtes
commissaire et lui dit je suis membre de
la commission des affaires étrangères
alors c'est la même chose regardez une
question très importante qui en débat en
ce moment les questions de défense
qu'est ce que vous voulez faire comme
politique européenne de défense ensemble
c'est ça l'objectif c'est trouver un
accord commun ans après c'est sûr qu'on
sera jamais d'accord sur plein de points
mais c'est trouver la meilleure solution
pour que ça arrange tout le monde les
anciens pays du bloc de l'est
la seule chose qui les intéresse l'otan
pour la sécurité l'europe pour les
subventions c'est pour ça qu'ils sont
rentrés et qu'est ce que vous préférez
d'abord votre sécurité ou les
subventions dans priorités vous pensez à
votre sécurité et vous voyez très bien
que tous ces pays là un des moments moi
je n'aurais pu faire une europe forte je
pense qu'on aurait pu la faire à 6 10 15
mais à partir du moment où on a intégré
ces pays là qui sont intimement liées à
la défense américaine et qui pensent que
l'otan mais leur seul salut ne feront
jamais rien qui puisse concurrencer les
états unis et l'europe ne fera jamais
rien c'est pour ça avec toute la
sympathie que j'ai pour vous je pense
que la conférence que vous faites très
intéressante mais
je pense que malheureusement je veux pas
vous décevoir ça débouchera sur rien
et là du coup ça c'est le conseil
européen j'ai pas de métier c'est ça
c'est beau c'est que c'est du bois ouais
j'ai entendu dire que il vous avez plus
du moins dans les 27 états européens
pour faire la façade
bonjour bonjour chahrazed fine aux
enquêtes chanter voilà bonjour voila
voila vous êtes ici le chef d'état se
réunissent ces impressionnantes c'est
impressionnant tapis rouge à d'accord
c'est pour nous aujourd'hui ce pauvre a
d'abord que gdf on passe sur le tapis
rouge et là je me dis mais je suis à un
endroit où emmanuel macron les mêmes les
anciens présidents et sont passés donc
trempe c'est impressionnant se dit on
est vraiment dans le pouvoir vrai de
vrai on va rentrer dans une salle de
plus importante où les décisions se
prennent oh là là
mais c'est magnifique assez
impressionnant et en fait cette salle on
la voit à la télé c'est pas là et c'est
à dire que chaque chef d'état soit jeudi
sa place si vous voulez essayer
alors je m'assois
un endroit que je vois à la télé en fait
je vois ça à la télé et je me dis je
suis assise sur le siège des manuels
macro donc là je me suis dit peut-être
président tel jour on sait pas c'est
mythique là
bonjour bonjour
de vous rencontrer venez vous venez dans
le nord j'ai exactement marcel c'est
exactement ça pourrait retirer le
maximum si on est autorisée avec la
distance c'est gentil un être sans être
sans masque moi j'ai une question vu
qu'on dansait conférence européenne
c'est que des citoyens est ce que vous
pensez qu'on doit faire des propositions
réalistes où on doit les faire
complètement utopique folle qu'est ce
que c'est comme ça au moins demain on
sait qu'on va être écouté aussi que ici
ce président est monsieur michel va
parler va dire d'écouter on a eu la
conférence europe et on a eu des
propositions extraordinaire et j'ai
vraiment impossible j'ai joué comme en
toute franchise
si je suis je suis et deux si je suis
égoïste je ne mettrai pas si je suis élu
je vous dirais fait des propositions
réalistes va faciliter magie sur le
débat d autres pays européens mais comme
je suis passionné et très convaincu par
cette ambition rébellion devons avoir
collectivement fait des propositions
utopiste on a besoin d'un idéal et je
pense est certes on a besoin maintenant
on a besoin que notre génération elle
est la même capacité de rêve d'idéal
d'utopie qui a été celle de ceux il ya
plus de 70 ans qui après cette bière
trail se sont dit on va changer le
modèle on va renverser la table et on va
bâtir un espace de paix prospérité c'est
ça qui s'est passé quand j'en parle j'ai
des frissons parce que je me souviens de
nos grands parents de vos grands parents
de tous ceux qui ont été victimes c'est
à dire mondial sur le sol européen et
partout dans le monde et je pense qu'on
a besoin maintenant de ce même de ce
même déclic celui des noms donc du coup
là aujourd'hui ma conférence de l'europe
à paris qui va avoir le
en fait on doit faire des propositions
utopiste allemand niva et les îles lau
rêve à lézignan et je croise on se donne
rendez-vous après le conseil européen
les pensées européen sera peut-être
plusieurs qui sont nécessaires qui se
pencheront sur les conclusions de la
conférence on peut se donner rendez-vous
et on verra allez je vais le nom de vous
remettre je suis dans ce qu'on appelle
être ambition qui je prends je prends au
mot alors là moi je consomme à faire une
signature monsieur
merci beaucoup merci merci
à l'article
très surpris qu'ils passaient pas qu'il
était c'est abordable si c'est pas
fait pour ces images trop à trois
risques
c'est incroyable que charazed et à
l'année puis rencontrer autant de
dirigeants à bruxelles donc si je
comprends bien en europe il y a le
conseil européen où se réunissent tous
les présidents et les premiers ministres
pour les grandes décisions il y a la
commission qui est un peu le
gouvernement de l'europe et puis il y a
le parlement européen où nous votons
directement pour nos députés ça
ressemble un peu à la france en fait
tiens que pour les autres participants à
la conférence comme romains ou antoine
qui voudrait que le latin devienne la
langue de leurs
fichiers et bien eux aussi ont voulu se
préparer avant l'étape nationale lors de
la conférence régionale à aubervilliers
il a été beaucoup question
d'environnement ils ont donc pris
contact avec françois gemenne un expert
du giec au mieux comprendre les enjeux
climatiques
moi j'avais une question que je voulais
vous poser parce que vous êtes
spécialiste les éoliennes jeune nico je
ne comprends poule les uns disent ces
magnifiques les autres disent c'est une
horreur d'autres disent pas chez moi
alors c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de
désinformation
concernant les éoliennes alors il ya
d'abord évidemment la question
esthétique voilà certains vont trouver
ça je vis dans le paysage dose on
trouvait ça affreux d'autres vont
prouver que ça défigure le paysage j'ai
envie de dire des goûts et des couleurs
ou jeu pas vraiment discuter mais c'est
certain qu'il n'y a pas d'énergie
parfaite l'idée d'une énergie parfaite
du monde isa absolument pas déchets
absolument pas contraintes
environnementales il faut l'oublier les
sciences par exemple au nucléaire qui
fait un peu des bas mais qui pour moi
est
et plus
pérenne qui pensent que les énergies
renouvelables est tout aussi vers
l'enfance où ça rejette en me les
déchets radioactifs ne rejette que de
l'eau pourquoi vous dites ça plus
pérenne puisque la durée de vie d'une
centrale nucléaire comparée à celle
d'une éolienne par exemple mais je
pourrais vous dire pour construire une
centrale nucléaire vous en avez pour au
moins quinze ans tandis qu'une éolienne
vous la construire en un mois
et par ailleurs vous le mettez violée en
afghanistan vous allez jamais allé
mettre des centrales nucléaires en
afghanistan il ya plein de pays
aujourd'hui
dans le monde qui n'ont pas ce réseau
d'électricité centralisée et wipro loire
si on veut électrifier les pays où il va
falloir des sources de production
beaucoup plus localisées beaucoup plus
petit il ya aujourd'hui encore d'énormes
besoins de développement où on parlait
de l'énergie il ya d'énormes besoins
d'électrification dans plein de pays et
il ya plein de pays qui ont ces
ressources dans leur sous-sol qui ont du
charbon ou du pétrole dans leur sous-sol
et qu'ils vont dire mais pourquoi est ce
qu'on ne peut pas utiliser ces
ressources et la question sous une
question pour vous romain et d'étudiants
donc j'imagine qu'ils avaient encore
énormément l'argent sur votre compte en
banque ou antoine vous êtes jean
immobilier donc j'espère que c'est un
peu mieux vous jure que je me
mets donc si je vous dis vous avez 1
millions d'euros au fond du jardin
mais si vous le déterrer savez de la
catastrophe pour l'humanité entière la
question c'est est-ce que vous avez déjà
déterré des millions et des millions de
pièces d'or et donc c'est compliqué mais
quand même la bonne nouvelle c'est que
je pense que c'est un sujet qui est
devenu de plus en plus important dans
les préoccupations des gens il ya
parfois des des bonnes surprises la
chine avance plus vite
qu'on ne le croyait dans le bon sens
c'est-à-dire que chaque année la chine
vient avec des annonces qui quelque part
dépasse les attentes des observateurs
alors la chine reste évidemment un gros
pays émetteur de gaz à effet de serre
mais les choses avancent plus vite en
chine qu'on ne l'avait imaginé
du travail mais vous savez la pente est
forte mais la route est droite dizaine
d'anciens premiers ministres oui c'est
vrai ça y est tous les français tirés au
sort dans l'es18 conférence régionale
commencent à arriver au palais d'iéna on
n'est pas loin de la tour eiffel
faut l'avouer cette seconde avoir pour
la première fois m quand on arrive on
voit la tour eiffel et la caisse
physique
impressionnante
il peut pas dire ça si le mouvement
magnifique de la france
on
va rentrer et
on va pouvoir ouvrir officiellement
maintenant cette conférence nationale
sur l'avenir de l'europe vous avez
réfléchi à 515
changements souhaités et 1300
propositions concrètes certaines très
aboutie un smic européen un bonus malus
pollution une armée européenne
un jour férié européen on a quand même
fait 1300 proposition concrets pour
changer l'europe de 2035 maintenant il
va falloir ramener tout ça à quelques
grandes priorités à présenter à nos
dirigeants
on a trois jours ici à paris pour se
mettre d'accord
à la fin de cet exercice marois je me
dis mais là c'est le moment d'en parler
il ya tous les citoyens soit une
française qui sont là de la france et
des dom tom donc c'est à ce moment là
qu'il faut parler bonjour à tous donc
c'est impressionnant de venir à paris
j'ai un message à faire passer est très
très important dont les parties un gros
sel rencontré charles michel si je vous
dis charles michels et qui
grand rigolo il est belge
pardon la commission exactement est
quasiment avec alan on a eu la chance
c'est pas de pression je conditionne
excusez moi de parler de la commision
c'est du conseil de l'europe et c'est là
où tout ça prend tout son sens au
conseil
ouais voilà abel conseils et je vais y
arriver je vais y arriver parce qu'on a
vu plein de personnes n'hésitent pas
important du conseil pour aux gars c'est
le président tu pensais en fait
c'est compliqué alors et tout s'est
passé comme israël se laisser faire j'ai
essayé de souffler un petit peu derrière
les soupers deux trois trucs mais moi
mais moi je ne savais pas tout mais elle
s'est bien débrouillé est ce que on doit
être réaliste
est-ce que les propositions aspects
peuvent être utopique est ce que ça peut
être le rêve et c'est la question que
j'ai posée à charles michel et il a dit
mais complètement et bien c'est vraiment
il faut sortir de la zone un peu de
confort et dieu de la réalité est ce
dire ben ben inventer des choses c'est
vraiment pousser les choses aujourd'hui
on a la chance de se réunir tous
ensemble on ait une diversité de ouf
commandiez de fond on peut dire tout ce
qu'on veut merci beaucoup pour ce témoin
faut arrêter de dire non mais c'est bon
toute façon y'a rien qui va se passer
mais en fait si on fait rien n'y a rien
qui se passe dans la vie donc
aujourd'hui c'est se dire ok là c'est là
donc c'est now ou never
[Musique]
donc là on va aller voir les
chaque fois nous ouais c'est ça
il déambule ils prennent connaissance
des thèmes des propositions en fait des
autres régions et une note sur un petit
calepin en fait leur bulletin de vote
les thèmes sur lesquels ils veulent
travailler armées européennes puissance
et diplomatique froid dans les relations
internationales ah ouais d'accord ok
aidé c'est que vous découvriez les
changements qui ont été proposés dans
toutes les régions sur ce thème une
europe puissante dans le monde et ce qui
est des points qui se rejoignent avec
des clivages est ce que il ya ça se
recoupent il ya des propositions qui
sont une très forte le fait de
de reléguer la souveraineté nationale
l'union européenne moi j'avoue que
j'adhère pas beaucoup à 7
je sais que ma vision est utopique et
que ce sera via un jour d'avoir un monde
avec pantois tous dans le même club et
mais que ça c'est pas possible parce
qu'il ne faut quand même au moins une
personne représentante de chacun pays
sinon on n'arrivera jamais à s'en sortir
je suis pour harmoniser le smic qu'à
terme en 2035 on est un smic comme un
acharné du travail qui soit à l'autre
bout de l'europe oui ils font du nom au
fin fond du sud ce soit le même cri
voilà alors on peut commencer par se
rendre compte que les poux sont pas
partout les mêmes noms mais aujourd'hui
c'est pour ça que je dis organisait
harmonisée parce que si on arrive à une
certaine
convergence les économies les prix vont
s'équilibrer mais toute façon tous ceux
qui disent tout doucement oui mais cette
année les roumains ont pris 30% de
salaire oui oui oui je lui en a pris
combien on a pris 2% à 3% non mais sur
les vingt dernières années qu il
ya la cohésion européenne
la conscience européenne qui passe du
coup par l'éducation qui passe par des
actes forts des actes symboliques comme
le jour férié comme éventuellement une
langue commune si vous permettez moi je
trouve intéressant l'idée instruire les
enfants dès l'école sur l'europe et
d'avoir comme programme scolaire un peu
comme un peu comme quand on apprend
l'anglais en maternelle n'est ce pas
également ton la france a de mettre en
place une décision commerciale avec le
japon et bien aujourd'hui tous les pays
européens ils doivent se réunir pour
savoir si les changes sera possible avec
le japon et s'il y en a un qui est pas
d'accord c'est bien il sera pas sera pas
mis en place et ça c'est quelque chose
qui est déjà fait en phase a concerné
pas toute l'europe c'était juste un pays
qui voulait mettre en place cet échange
tout l'europe au havre 28 e et maxime on
a un marché commun pour ces deux réputés
le fait que tous doivent être d'accord
tchèque se payer un droit de veto peu
importe sa capacité de provisions qui
justement réputés savent pas ce que
c'est c'est ce que les roses ans a fait
une inertie énorme parce que dès qu'on
veut prendre une décision je fis qui est
un pays qui est qui qui soit pas
d'accord pour mettre aucune décision qui
sera prise et l'europe n'est plus aucun
pouvoir en pleines mais là c'est là où
il ya eu 10 mener
une manière d'arriver à un accord commun
c'est comme quand tu es dans une ferme
justement il n'y a aucun accord n'est
trouvé parce que il ya toujours un qui
va être
voilà sa tenue sa famille en a toujours
eu donc il faut trouver la solution en
commun c'est pour ce grain dans les
faits quand même les grands pays
arrivent à mettre la pression aux petits
pays pour pour faire accepter les choses
souvent même si on est décidé
[Musique]
le soir on arrive au quai d'orsay avec
des cartes vip
[Musique]
mais c'est magnifique vous êtes tous
bois si l'on se dit ouah ou quoi
t'imagines rooney
alors où
je me rendais de largeur de tonnes
à nos femmes à nos chevaux et à ce qu'il
vaut
[Musique]
on dirait mon salon
au moins bien
moi j'appelle ma mère je voulais appeler
mes soeurs et ma mère parce que je me
disais mais je suis quelque part où
c'est pas possible je voulais partager
sous je suis le quai d'orsay même un
regard l'illustrent fait vraiment ce que
tu aimes regarderai
james à la télé je suis dans la télé en
a marre elle adore tout ce qui est bling
bling et tout ça et c'est vraiment ça
avec l'illustré tout elle dit ouah
bonsoir à toutes et à tous pardon de
vous interrompre dans un moment qui a
l'air déjà très convivial et très
chaleureux je suis clément ball le
secrétaire d'état aux affaires
européennes très heureux de vous
recevoir ici ce soir au quai d'orsay
vous avez répondu parfois au départ je
crois un coup de fil un peu étrange au
début de l'été qui vous disent est ce
que voulait parler d'europe en week-end
et vous avez été suffisamment fou pour
dire oui merci à tous
un jour j'ai envie de me rencontrer à
l'honneur des 27 états nous avons
aujourd'hui comme on pourrait le
harmoniser un peu tout ça pour justement
parce que en voulant faire une europe ça
veut dire qu'on va avoir des lois
communes des vals de choses de 100
années j'ai un peu mais je pense que
paradoxalement et pour acheter ensemble
je pense qu'il faut accepter de
différencier sur son bras sur les grands
la rive pas tous d'accord à 27 c'est
quoi une idée folle pour vous
concrètement à l'état fédéral mais vous
dire les ruches parce que c'est souvent
les idées les plus concrètes schuman est
dit on ferait des réalisations concrètes
et des solidarités de fait quand vous
dites il faut tous les jeunes dans les
dix ans qui viennent s'est tous fait 6
mois 1 an l'étranger ça paraît assez
difficile
c'est vraiment ça c'est des idées
simples qui existe déjà mais lise
élargir et à avoir une élite qu'il
puisse le faire mais que ce soit
accessible à tout le monde
[Musique]
après les petits fours dans un palais de
la république allez au boulot c'est à
nous de jouer on a tous choisi notre
groupe de travail
moi je suis dans le groupe e set up
c'est la démocratie
et après le groupe catalan
moi de mon côté j'ai choisi le groupe
une europe qui met l'éducation au
premier plan car la jeunesse c'est notre
avenir
faisons un petit tour de table en sont
des petites pistes et il ya le chai de
pouvoir
mieux s'approprier l'histoire de l'autre
d'ailleurs on l'a dans la toute première
la toute première proposition
approfondir l'enseignement de l'histoire
et la géographie de l'europe moi je
pense que effectivement l'histoire elle
s'apprend pas seulement à l'école tel ce
elles se partagent aussi à travers les
déplacements à travers l'europe et les
changes peuvent vous couper ce n'est pas
donné à tous d'avoir des finances
ce n'est pas donné à tout non plus de
pouvoir avoir la possibilité de voyager
voyager c'est hyper important il faut
aller voir dans le pays ce qui se passe
c'est peut-être un coup mais entre les
écoles s'il arrive à trouver les bons
moyens pour le bon équilibre et bien en
fait demain je vais en pologne demain je
vais en suède demain soir en italie et
en fait on échangeait en fait on va
dernier famille c'est encore plus
productif parce qu'on va vivre
localement les vrais terre de tradition
on va apprendre différentes cultures et
ça ça peut être gratuit en fait au final
parce qu'on rééquilibre entre les deux
les deux pays et les échanges mans
[Musique]
le smic en 2035 on s'était dit que
c'était quelque chose qui
qu'il était qui était un changement en
tant que terre et qui permettait de
fusionner plusieurs est ce que vous
voyez d'autres choses les travailleurs
détachés travaille pas le même nombre
d'heures que nous on travaille du lundi
au vendredi par exemple ou un travail du
mardi au samedi web ces gens là
travaillent moins six jours par semaine
ils travaillent plus dur ce que nous et
en plus et il travaille avec pas les
mêmes normes de sécurité que nous moi je
vois je suis dans le bâtiment mois pour
changer nos gouvernements ne prennent
pire ils vont monter sur une échelle et
sur une chaise et voit très bien face à
nous avec des échafaudages avec ici
presque sur l'épaule de l'autre il fait
et je sais pas si ça existe ou pas les
expertises ont peut-être mais tout ça on
peut mettre un code de travail européen
qui dit voilà aujourd'hui pour
travailler il ya une cote travail
européen et qu'on travaille c'est pour
moi le tous les employeurs de ces jeux
se baser à ce code du travail est au
minimum c'est comme une convention
collective et les eplug au niveau
d'égalité des chances on avait évoqué
l'idée
d'un petit capital en fait qui est
versée dès la naissance attention c'est
pas des millions d'euros au delà c'est
qu'un jeune de 18 ans se retrouve en
possession d'un capital de 2000 euros
qui pourrait lui permettre effectivement
de se payer un permis de commencer un
petit projet pour s'émanciper après qui
serait financé il faut imaginer que
celle-là financement sur 18 ans donc
d'un individu
je me suis trompé nouveau et je me suis
trouvé dans le groupe des personnes de
voulaient faire de l'écologie tonnes il
ya beaucoup d'endroits où il n'ya pas de
compteurs d'eau
et
c'est là que il ya des pertes de
gaspillage
si les gens ne payent pas l'eau si même
on ne sait pas ce qu'ils consomment et
un gaspillage si on met des compteurs
d'eau dans un immeuble qui n'en a pas
c'est à dire c'est chaque occupant
pessonneaux on divise par deux voire
trois la facture d'eau st je le sais par
expérience
alors parce que d'un point de vue
européen s'est pas homogène parce qu'on
en irlande ip paulo et ben c'est une
erreur est une erreur il y en a j'ai
vécu cinq ans la
prescription du coup dans le changement
qu'on voulait on peut dire on peut
parler d'harmonisation ce n'est pas un
musée mais la recycler et mieux
contrôler
non c'est pas ça c'est non c'est pas ça
c'est savoir ce que les gens consomment
c'est à dire l'acte une ressource
universel fanuc où tu peux pas
mais je dis pas qu'il faut priver les
gens mais moi je veux savoir ce qu'ils
consomment il y avait aucune discipline
de parole j'ai pratiquement pas réussi à
parler je vois les écologistes je
m'excuse mais assez indisciplinés
servir à t'as pas vu ce matin
7h du mat c'est moi qui ai ouvert la
salle vous étiez pas là je suis repartie
elle nous protège du coup avec ce
matinée pour vous ça le changement par
rapport aux régionales on est trop sûr
du caractère il n'y a pas assez de
imagination je pense qu'on pense trop
individuel et pas assez
sur la changer de groupe les personnes
qui vont entrer dans un nouveau groupe
va peut-être rajouter des propositions
et bourque loin parce que tu travailles
souvent que chiquita mater tout petit
d'un travail tu vois que dans le fait
d'arriver quelque chose de nouveau tu as
des idées tu proposes to n'importe quoi
beaucoup de propositions et ses draps de
soie c'est une aventure qui existe déjà
et les gens sont pas du tout au courant
donc donc c'est là où ceux ci je te
disais tout à l'heure c'est qu'il ya
vraiment un problème d'information de
communication de l'europe et c'est
quelque chose qu'on n'a pas qu'on n'a
pas on n'a pas vraiment compris ça et je
pense qu'on le rappelle manque de
stratégie un peu de vision à la tendance
à au dernier moment quand il ya un sujet
il ya la crise des migrants et à kobe ne
sais pas quoi du coup on lui fit le
plein de compétences parce que
fils de bébé avec l'eau chaude du bateau
et mais
c'est pas quelque chose de papier c'est
au dernier moment parce que nécessité
fait loi elles interviennent et
décrivait
comment les états unis stockent plus de
croissance en europe sera quelques
années à venir chacun des ateliers a
fait une première liste de changements
concrets par domaine et c'est à moi de
présenter dans l'hémicycle devant tout
le monde ce qu'on voudrait pour
l'éducation nous souhaiterions en 2035
que tous les citoyens puissent apprendre
ou au mieux parler plusieurs langues et
notamment en en ayant toujours une
commune afin de pouvoir tous échanger
ensemble et de tous pouvoir se
comprendre sans interférer sur toutes
les cultures linguistique et du
patrimoine de chaque pays
parce que c'est ce qui fait notre force
au sein de l'europe nous souhaiterions
aussi en 2035 un accès à de nouveaux
horizons qui se réfère à travers des
voyages erasmus à tout âge et pour tous
milieux professionnels ou aussi scolaire
je vous remercie
j'accueille allen qui a la lourde tâche
de clore cette séquence
avec une europe qui protège bonjour à
tous à la 9 e de la région paca au début
nous avions 50 heureusement et nous
avons nous sommes arrivés à synthétiser
tout cela à 1 4 grands changements donc
harmoniser la santé est il à rendre
accessible à tous les citoyens européens
un travail plus égalitaire en europe
avec la création d'un salaire minimum
dans tous les états membres et la mise
en place d'un code de travail européen
merci à tous
c'est infiniment à tous les participants
sur ces pitchouns hyper efficace on est
bluffé par votre capacité de synthèse et
surtout la qualité des des propos droit
au fur et à mesure du processus que ce
qui est au départ quelque chose d'assez
général on veut une europe plus verte en
venant plus forte on veut une europe
plus respectés externe il arrive à des
choses précises concrètes est assez
bluffante parfois une proposition qui
est venu répéter régionaux et jusqu'à la
fin et ça paraît tout bête c'est une
police européenne de l'environnement
pour que les mêmes règles pour protéger
nos cours d'eau les usines qui polluent
empêcher ça et c'est un bon bah ça c'est
super concrets pour corser un peu les
choses les organisateurs ont eu l'idée
de changer les groupes je dois aller
dans l'atelier une europe plus unie pour
leur donner mon avis sur leurs
propositions
unifier la voix de l'europe à
l'international faire de la politique
extérieure une compétence exclusive de
lui concrètement ça voudrait dire que la
france n'aurait pu 2007 affaires
étrangères
ni l'allemagne ni l'italie ni l'espagne
mais il y aurait un ministre des
affaires étrangères européens qui
représenterait l'europe dans son
intégralité partout dans le monde et je
voyais dans l'eure
avoir une seule ambassade européenne par
ferry à la place de toutes les
ambassades ci existe
des fois déjà dans certaines ambassades
c'est déjà un peu le bordel
donc si on avait une porte les pays ça
risque d'être tous les services
comment dire
même dans numérique c'est l'omerta alors
[Musique]
je reviens sa première proposition sur
l'idée d'une éducation donc initial
européenne avec un socle de
connaissances communes la partie
enseignement
de mes souvenirs c'est des cours très
académique sur comment fonctionne
l'europe et
moi j'aurais imaginé plus quelque chose
de vraiment participatif avec des sortes
de groupes de travail un peu à l'image
de ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui où en fait
chaque élève étudiant pourrait prendre
par la décision et faire une sorte de je
sais pas peut-être en primaire par
exemple faire une sorte de vote
démocratique où il reproduire est un peu
le fonctionnement de de l'europe pour
voter je ne sais pas le menu à la
cantine ou des choses un peu lentes
comme ça et et ludique et après à
différentes échelles augmenter un peu le
domaine de compétence quitte à ce que ce
soit même profitable et qu'on fasse des
réelles groupe de travail avec des
résultats qui puissent être utilisés
après pour l'europe parce que non
seulement on peut être utopique on nous
a dit
m
c'est un très bel hymne à la joie
la joie c'est quand même que l'hymne que
voyons donc minéraux bus des trains
votre
santé
c'est la joie
[Musique]
pour moi c'est une journée qui a
commencé de manière assez dense intense
avec avis très tranché j'avais beaucoup
de points clivant c'est dur pour les
facilitateurs fin c'est dur pour tout le
monde parce que y compris pour les
citoyens c'est très intense à de
travailler toute la journée de débattre
de défendre ses idées j'ai un point
d'attention sur un citoyen qui est
arrivé à midi ce matin qui est assez
problématique dans les échanges il prend
la parole très longtemps de manière
assez cynique et qui sera dans mon
groupe demain matin si le soleil
[Musique]
le playa drac le giaba en espagne
mais bon j'ai suivi le mouvement
salute
une liste des plats
peux pas je suis déjà tombé amoureux
d'elle au premier regard j'aimerais pas
une blague tant d'émotions comme petit
coeur à palpiter
[Musique]
que ce soit la photo c'est vraiment
moins que soigner
les rhumes et les bras en l'air
[Musique]
c'est fait
on va regarder un beau souvenir c'est le
dernier jour certains ont fait la fête
hier soir mais on est quand même tous
sur le pont ce matin
dans chaque groupe on leur demande de
faire leur top 3 qu est-ce que vraiment
ils volent ils veulent voir émerger dans
le groupe sur lequel ils ont travaillé
c'est chaud dans mon groupe sur
l'éducation pour savoir quel sera notre
proposition numéro une celle qui sera
mise en avant les envies de chacun
est-ce qu'on peut refaire un tour de
table
table on peut refaire un tour de table
donc du coup il ya trois propositions
c'est ce qui en rouge intégrer une
matière civique européenne concours
civique étoiles renforcement de
l'apprentissage des langues européennes
dès le plus jeune âge et programmes des
changes tout au long de la vie c'était
la priorité voilà la proposition en
rupture avec ce qui est déjà fait c'est
l'intégration d'une matière civique sur
l'europe pour moi c'est ça comporte ça
doit être le grand titre matière civique
européen sébastien le corse veut un
cours d'éducation civique européenne
dans tous les pays alors que la
marseillaise chahrazed milite pour un
renforcement de l'apprentissage des
langues s'ils comptent pour du beurre la
comédie et ce n'est pas le docteur
maintenant du nez aux oubliettes c'est
fini donc en plus jeunes il sera jamais
question c'est parce que l'optimiste où
l'on fait des promotions alors que
sébastien et 10 est assez bon ma
proposition n'est pas sorti c'est sûr
c'est beau ça va pas fonctionner une est
restée sur sa proposition alors qu en
fait j'en avais tellement il ya 1300
propositions donc en fait peu importe ce
qu'on va dire l'essentiel c'est d'en
parler c'est d'en discuter c'est de
sortir des choses après donc qu'on soit
d'accord si on choisit par exemple
renforcement de l'apprentissage des
langues alors juste le projet c'est dire
bah on va mettre trois heures d'anglais
en plus chacun de ses pas cher à toi
t'as pas compris c'est qu'aujourd'hui
c'est se dire que quand tu commences à
arriver à l'école c'est d'intégrer tout
de suite des langues est avant tout non
mais le niveau aujourd'hui il n'est pas
il est pas comme si tu
allais à l'écroulement des trois qui est
pour le intégré européennes commencent
à intégrer
ensuite les d'accord sur le renforcement
de l'apprentissage élan en position qui
serait en position une sur cette
proposition là qui est d'accord une
personne clé d'accord pour la trois
programmes des changes toujours la vie
positionnement qu'une 2 3 4 5 6 voilà
c'est bien la première
laisse contribuer pour voter je crois
que ces
sujets d'accords tout à l'heure on va
faire en valais dans l'hémicycle et en
fait ça se trouve cette proposition va
sortir et se sera pas celle qu'on a dit
oh là là tu te bloque
je trouve c'est toujours ceux ci
n'y a pas que ça ait encore d'autres
propositions mais voit un pitch d'une
minute je propose pour aller vite de
reprendre notre championne qui l'a fait
si bien la dernière fois ils élisent
voilà donc question éléments de langage
que l'on peut apporter et qui permettent
de le prendre fait présenter cette cette
proposition est celle dont quimper à moi
que revient la lourde tâche de présenter
les propositions de changement
prioritaire de notre groupe devant tous
les autres c'est un honneur mais c'est
aussi une sacrée responsabilité
il va falloir trouver les bombes en 2035
nous retrouverons goût aux systèmes non
ça va pas
non ça va pas en 2035 l'accès à de
nouveaux horizons sera fait à travers
sera fait à travers le programme des
changes qui sera tout au long de la vie
si c'est bien son nom mais sinon tu fais
simple il se regarde là que tu fais trop
de phrases ne faut pas que tu dis tout a
culminé au tchad
[Musique]
développer la sobriété énergétique pour
consommer moins en arrêtant le superflu
ces changements que nous souhaitons pour
une europe engagé face au défi
climatique et environnementale bien que
cette idée puisse paraître évidente elle
est novatrice et innovante dans la
politique européenne la sobriété c'est
consommer moins la sobriété c'est
ramener de la raison de consommation ce
programme que l'on souhaiterait mettre
en place permettrait de développer et de
diversifier erasmus pour toutes les
personnes et que ce ne soit pas réservé
simplement aux universités ou alors que
ce soit pas réservée à une certaine
pardon catégories de personnes mais je
finirai quand même sur le fait que nous
ne devons faire qu'un et c'est en étant
unie face à la diversité que l'on est
plus fort avec notre groupe nous avons
travaillé sur le thème d'une europe
garante du respect des droits
fondamentaux et nous avons proposé de
définir une politique commune permettant
d'améliorer l'accueil l'intégration
sociale et professionnelle des migrants
et y compris des migrants en situation
irrégulière
harmoniser la santé et la rendre
accessible à tous les européens c'est
bien citoyenne
pensez ce que vous voulez pensez à tous
mes pensées surtout à la joie populaire
car comme nous le disions tout à l'heure
c'est la joie populaire qui est la
preuve la réussite des programmes
merci michel
ça fonctionne à l'applaudimètre
normalement et merci pour vos
encouragements pour ce groupe
conclusion c'est vous qui allez
maintenant travailler pour
sélectionner choisir prioriser vos trois
changements préférées
[Musique]
c'est moi merci
à voter un poteau
on va refaire une petite photo parce
qu'on a vraiment bien aimé ça uniquement
les citoyen uniquement les citoyens
regardez moi bien comme tout à leur
grand sourire à 2,3 voilà on est bon
merci beaucoup
vient maintenant une séquence que tout
le monde attend qui est le résultat de
vos votes
de partager si vous le voulez bien le
résultat numéro 3 donc du changement qui
est arrivé en numéro 3
c'était favoriser la performance
économique collective à travers une
industrie autonome compétitive et qui
est valorisé par lieu donc c'était une
une europe qui défend ses intérêts donc
voilà en fait l'idéal est simple c'est
seul on va plus vite mais à plusieurs on
voit donc voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
rased la deuxième proposition du coup
qui a été retenu c'est renforcer la
défense et la sécurité commune donc ce
qui représente une europe présente dans
le monde pour être plus puissant bien
sûr voilà donc ça c'est la deuxième
proposition a été votée
la première intention
ou à tout le moins bon ok alors la
première
c'est un sujet qui nous touche tous
puisque sa touche au changement
climatique s'est développée la sobriété
je me connais beaucoup en sobriété
développer la sobriété énergétique pour
consommer en arrêtant le superflu alors
c'est une europe engagé face au défi
climatique
et
enfin une robe longue est face au défi
climatique est un mot que j'arrive pas à
lire donc
de quoi et l'environnement merci
donc voilà c'est qu'on me dira c'est la
santé de notre planète et quand la santé
va tout va et voilà
c'est important
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
toi tu te retrouves dans ses choix c'est
est ce que tu avais sélectionnés moi
j'avais surtout sélectionner la sécurité
la puissance ses collègues puisque c'est
ma formation beaucoup bossé sur scène
j'avais way et et puis qu'on ait mis en
premier le fait de pas fichés la planète
ont l'air ça ne me paraît pas
extravagant c'est bien
toi je te remercie pour tout les pieds
judo
on a nos contacts respectifs voilà bon à
bientôt
moi je crois qu'on a fait un beau
travail
l'initiative
au départ on ne se sentait pas forcément
légitime pour donner notre avis sur
l'avenir de l'europe vu qu'aucun d'entre
nous n'était spécialistes on est partis
de loin mais on est arrivé à faire dix
propositions de changement pour l'europe
de 2035
maintenant il faut que ça serve à
quelque chose et je fais partie de ceux
qui vont devoir présenter les résultats
au ministre je ne m'attendais pas une
aussi grande réunion je stresse à fond
je fais même une petite répétition
messieurs les ministres messieurs les
représentants de l'état
j'ai une question selon-vous l'europe
réussira t-elle
la refait
ok
merci
si bien d'une lancé
j'attends le rapport
ouais j'espère j'espère pas
besoin d'avoir des deux d'une europe en
danger face au défi climatique et
environnementale
bonjour à tous monsieur ministre
mesdames messieurs les représentants de
l'état j'ai une question selon-vous
l'europe réussira t-elle d'ici 2035 à
faire face aux défis climatiques et
environnementaux
je vous le dis l'europe réussira son
pari si vous nous donner les moyens d'y
arriver
lors des diverses conférences régionales
ce sujet était au coeur des discussions
sur quatorze familles de souhaits de
était dédiée à ce thème remportant le
vote lors de la conférence nationale bon
je te vois bien un numéro un ce climat
complètement surpris et numéro 2 c'est
la sécurité la défense je pensais pas
que c'est aussi fort peut-être que c'est
français on va voir les autres pays mais
il ya un sentiment très fort que
l'europe doit enfin passer à l'idée
qu'elle fait aussi des choses difficiles
car se fait respecter quelques règles
d'être une armée demain en tout cas vu
capacité d'intervention et ce terrain et
ça c'est très fort voilà c'est la fin de
cette conférence sur l'avenir de
l'europe
[Musique]
on est sorti de notre zone de confort on
a eu des doutes on a donné notre avis le
taux est monté parfois on a trouvé des
compromis on a aussi dû surmonter notre
traque pour parler en public ça a
vraiment été une belle aventure humaine
que je n'oublierai jamais depuis plus de
70 ans l'europe s'était toujours fait
par les élites maintenant qu'on nous a
demandé notre avis à nous on ne doit
plus lâcher le micro et on va aussi bien
tenir à l'oeil ce qui va être fait de
nos propositions
[Applaudissements]
il faut vraiment que notre travail soit
pris en compte et ça je le demande
gentiment mais fermement
à à tous les dirigeants à qui nos
travaux seront communiqués et ils ont
compté sur nous je pense ne comptons
vraiment sur eux
merci d'avancé
[Musique]